Alright,
we are back.
I jokingly said that we were going to
crash the Internet and I'm pretty sure
we crashed youtube literally out of
every live stream we have ever done.
We have never had an issue.
I don't know what happened there.
I have conferred with these two fine men
and we're not willing to completely go
down the conspiracy theory yet.
We're going to have to just recap what
happened in 10 minutes,
I believe.
Well,
first off,
Ben Shapiro to my left,
ironically,
Jordan Peterson to my right.
Uh,
I believe that we are fully right now in
an idea revolution.
We talked about this for about 10
minutes.
We'll try to recap a little bit of what
we started with and then gets a similar
all new stuff.
Uh,
as I've said to the guys,
they're welcome to talk directly to each
other.
If they have questions for me,
we can add.
There are no rules here,
there are never rules in your,
but truly today,
there are no rules.
Uh,
and I,
I think that these guys are in the thick
of something just tremendously important
right now in relevant.
And that's why they're blowing up the
way that they are.
Okay.
Let's try to do some of that again.
Although you guys were both quite
eloquent the 10 minutes ago.
I'm idea revolution.
Do you believe that we are in an idea
revolution right now?
Well,
this is what I think's happening,
I think,
and I think this accounts for the
attractiveness of the content that I've
put on Youtube.
So when Nisha darkness the death of God
about 150 years ago and his,
he made three predictions,
he said people will be,
as a consequence,
our culture will shape to the roots will
become nihilistic or totalitarian in
response,
or we'll invent our own values.
Okay?
Those were.
Those were his three possibilities.
And then,
and then of course we became not listed.
Can Totalitarian,
totalitarian through the 20th century
and many tens of millions of people died
as a consequence,
which Nietzsche also foretold
specifically.
He said that 100 million people would
die because of the rise of communist
ideas.
He said that in willpower.
So then he predicted that while we would
have to invent our own values,
but then the psychoanalysts came along
and they said,
well wait a second,
you can't.
You can't create your own values because
you're not mastering your own house.
There are forces operating inside of you
that are autonomous.
And for Freud,
those were primarily biological forces,
but young took that a step further and
he said,
well wait a minute.
Biology is a lot more sophisticated and
complex than you think,
and there are symbolic forces at work.
He thought of the archetypes has images
of the instincts,
for example,
but the instincts were a lot more
sophisticated than people thought.
So it's not just an instinct to
aggression.
Let's say there's an instinct to
operating properly that you walk up
hierarchies,
human hierarchies of competence.
It'd be something like that.
And that's.
That's an archetype of the ideal.
In some sense,
you thought the gods didn't disappear.
They went inside,
they went into the psyche,
and so he dove down as far as he could
dive to find out what those eternal
images were and to bring them back up to
the surface.
And that's what I've been continuing,
I would say in my lectures saying,
look,
there's,
there are elements to the ancient story
that are not only they're deeply correct
and you cannot live and you live in hell
unless you know them.
It's something like that.
And that's the case.
So.
And I think that's,
I'm hoping that's what is happening is
that people are starting to understand
that people,
people's lives do have a transcendent
purpose.
That's the most appropriate way of
looking at life.
That our brains are in fact evolved to
reveal that purpose to us.
Which I also believe.
I think the neuro neurological evidence
in that regard is quite clear.
I believe that.
And so I hope.
I'm hoping that what,
what we're.
We're at the end of postmodern despair.
That's what I'm hoping.
Yeah.
So to me,
what you're giving there is sort of a
realist version of religion.
You're saying these stories are needed
for a very real way.
I suspect you basically agree with.
Well,
what's what's fascinating about this is
a,
I mean Jordan,
maybe closer to aristotle and Plato,
but I think that we almost have a
platonic verses,
Aristotelian argument going on here
because it seems like what you're
talking about is the idea that if we dig
down deep enough into our biology's and
into our neural networks,
what we find is a common set of shared
values that if you refuse to acknowledge
then leads to grave on happiness.
And what I'm.
I'm almost feeling level right and when
I'm coming from,
it's almost a platonic idea,
which is that the mind of man reflects
the mind of God to the extent that you
can.
That not only is,
is I would argue that that extra
revelation is necessary,
but even if you don't use revelation,
that using your capacity to reason,
you can find a purpose in something
about.
But we ended up at the same place.
Which is the set of values that if you
actually,
uh,
if you,
if you stray away from this common set
of values,
and I'm talking like the most root level
values,
personal responsibility,
free will.
It's your job to be responsible for
members of your family.
It's your job to make good decisions and
responsible decisions and not to blame
the society around you for failures that
you are yourself responsible for.
You can't surpass your own innate
capacity in,
in,
in terms of you can't expect society to
make up for your lack of innate capacity
in certain areas.
You just have to make the most of what
you have in front of you.
You and I agree on values,
but I think that the source of the
values,
there's going to be a slight
disagreement on I think.
I think it's okay.
It's a,
it's a.
it's a profound place for disagreement
because,
and I don't understand how to mediate it
exactly because I'm not willing to
dispense with the metaphysical.
No.
When I did my biblical lectures last
year,
I called him a psycho psychological
approach.
The biblical stories,
right?
Because I wanted to push a secular
interpretation of scientific
interpretation by the stories is just
not to interrupt.
I think that that's supremely useful to
people specifically because I mean,
despite the fact that I come from a
religious background,
I'm trying to make arguments that are
not religious in orientation.
I never cite to the Bible when I talk
about values,
for example,
I never site revelation.
It's valuable to me because I think that
that's a good source of the values and I
think that it's an irrelevant source of
the values,
but it is not the only way to achieve
those values.
I've never suggested,
for example,
that atheists can be moral or that you
can be an agnostic and not believe in
Judeo Christian systems.
Revelation and comes to the same exact
set of values that we're talking about
now is also a simpler argument to make
because you constrain the number of
necessary.
Very exactly.
But having said that,
I'm not willing to dispense with the
metaphysical and I think like,
I think it's an I'm like stretching the
edges of my cognitive ability when I'm
talking about this sort of thing because
I'm in realms that I don't understand
that it's,
that I just getting vague pictures.
Um,
but I think it's as if there's a,
there's a revelation,
a revelation from evolution that matches
the revelation from above.
The two things come together and,
and I don't under,
I don't understand how that can be
possible.
I think it has something to do with the
fundamental nature of consciousness,
which is something we seriously do not
understand.
And so I can see you can make a straight
biological case for the evolution of
archetypes.
But I don't think that the biological
explanation exhausts the archetype.
There's more to it and it,
and what I've learned to and delving
into these religious stories but also
into religious experience is that it's
bottomless.
Like there is a point where as you dig
into the architectural,
everything turns into one thing.
Biological,
spiritual,
transcendent.
It's all one thing from the top to the
bottom.
And I think people get intimations of
that when they have profound
experiences,
experiences that are generated by music,
for example,
if I love or by sex or there's a variety
of ways that they can be.
Anytime you have an experience of
meaning in your life.
And I can also see that.
And I believe this to be the case is
that you are,
you're neurologically adapted to a
universe where meaning is the highest
instinct.
And I mean that technically is that when
you're sitting in a situation where
what's happening around you is
meaningful,
what your nervous system is signaling to
you is that you occupy the optimal
position in the dynamic territory that
you currently inhabit.
And that's,
and that sense of meaning is it's not
just cortical,
it's,
it's way deeper than merely cortical.
And so that's a very exciting.
That's a very exciting discovery.
I would say that I think that because
again,
in a place where we agree is that
meaning is uncovered.
It's not some,
it's discovered.
It's not something that you're making up
yourself.
And that's why I think it's revealed.
Exactly.
And because we're like happiness.
And I think that one of the reasons
that,
that the message that we're putting out
there is,
is making people happier.
Actually,
even though we're both pessimist by
nature,
I would think a,
is that what
we're basically saying is that in this
land of chaos where you could be
wandering around with no meaning there
is a meaning and if you search for it,
you'll find it,
but you have to be open to the concept
that there is a meaning to be
discovered.
And if you shut yourself off from that
by just saying there's no meaning to be
discovered,
meaning as to be made up by you and you
can just do what you want to have.
A phenomenal thing is just,
it's just something that you
experienced,
but it's not really real.
That,
that kind of stuff is,
is,
uh,
I think disquieting to people.
And so there's something that quiets the
soul that says you have purpose.
And if you don't have purpose,
then maybe it's because you're searching
in the wrong place for that purpose.
That's a possibility.
That's really interesting things that
you said there because it's like I know
you guys pretty well at this point and
this crew of people that were sort of in
when,
when we're off camera,
we're actually talking about the exact
same things like we are live.
Whether this camera was on right now are
off like we're living this thing all the
time.
I think I can speak from my own
experience in this regard.
It's made me a better person and I will
and I'm still striving to be about a
more authentic,
a more honest.
I'm constantly.
I mean I sit in this chair when it's
over there and look at the person over
here every week and I actually here and
I listen and I sit across great minds
and I go,
wow,
I have to reevaluate some of the things
that I think and sometimes it's because
I disagree with someone or you know,
and I'm like,
they really don't know what they're
talking about,
but often it's hopefully that I'm
hearing somebody say some great.
This is what's really interesting.
And I think what's,
what's great about conversations like
this one is when.
Yeah,
if I have Jordan on my facebook live and
I asked him questions or he'll have me
on his youtube and he's asking
questions,
what we're all really in the business of
all of us who are occupying the space is
asking questions or treated as weird
because we're asking the questions.
Right?
If you're actually listening to the
answers.
Exactly.
Because I always think,
well,
you know,
you might have something to tell me.
That's my rule number 11.
By the way,
I assume that the person you're
listening to might know something you
don't,
right?
Because then you can,
they can tell you about to you and if
you learn it then you don't have to run
face first into a brick wall.
It's really helped.
And then it and from Jewish tradition
that's deeply embedded in Jewish
tradition that the wise man is the man
who learns from every man around him.
And so this idea is,
is,
is what unifies this really disparate
stream of people.
The three of us people like Sam Harris,
people like Joe Rogan.
I mean like you look at me and Joe Rogan
and what we have in right?
We like asking questions and we will
actually look like you might be
different species.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
that's how I found the same thing when I
was on Jocko willink podcast.
It's like,
you know,
we're,
we're very different people,
but that's what's in common is that
we're able to have a conversation.
We're actually able to have a
conversation and,
and that we're aiming.
I think we're,
we're all aiming at making things better
rather than worse,
which is also a very important thing to
massively.
One of the things that makes that happen
is the fact that we are,
as you say,
talking about first principles all the
time.
When people talk at the top of the
iceberg,
then it's impossible for them to even
see sometimes that they're actually
standing on two different icebergs
rather than they're not seeing the
commonalities of,
of,
and they're not seeing what's different.
Like if I,
if I argue first principles with
somebody,
then you can see how those first
principles manifest in political
differences.
The business that I'm in.
Um,
but if you're just arguing about a
certain political policy without
examining anything that goes underneath
there,
then you just ended up clubbing each
other and not even understanding what
the other person's saying because you
don't understand the set of values that
deriving those political principles.
Part of the problem that we have right
now in our culture is trying to diagnose
the level at which the discussion should
be taking place.
And I think the reason that this is a
tumultuous time is because it actually
is a time for discussion of first
principles and it's,
it's that first principles are virtually
at the level of theology.
Because first principles are the things
that you assume and then move forward.
It's like,
well,
what should we assume while the dignity
of the human soul,
but start with that.
You can't treat yourself properly
without assuming that you can't have a
relationship with another person.
You can't stabilize your family.
You can't have a functional society.
So what does it mean for the human soul
have dignity?
Well,
the part of the idea is that you're
participating in creation itself and you
do that with your actions.
And your language and you get to decide
whether you're tilting the world a bit
more towards heaven or a bit more
towards hell and that's actually what
you're doing.
So that's a place where the literal and
metaphorical truth come together and
people are very,
they're terrified of that idea as they
should be because it's a massive
responsibility.
It's a massive realization of
responsibility to understand that all
the decisions that you make during the
day,
our decisions between Hell and heaven
essentially.
But I think there is no truer way of
saying that.
So as you guys have both sort of hit the
level that you're at.
And I was at the turning point thing
with you a couple of weeks ago and you
literally came out.
It was like the rolling stones came out.
I mean people.
People were going bananas.
I talked about all my political
differences with them that we've
discussed about being pro choice and for
gay marriage.
Although they are basically okay with
that and,
and being pro pot and all that.
And I got a standing ovation.
We did our thing and in Clemson and the
line for you after,
it was longer than the line for me and I
told you this,
but I was like,
man,
that makes me want to be better.
I have to.
I wasn't jealous of you.
I was like,
man,
he's doing something great and I have to
be better.
So my question for you is this was all
meant to be right.
I mean without going too religious or
metaphysical,
but the Internet has now allowed all of
the people that were watching television
and seeing pop culture and going
something is really wrong here.
Something is missing.
The Internet has sort of forced us
together.
I mean that's this,
this growing group is because we're.
It's not because we're all looking for
it.
It's because we're being forced
together.
Well,
it's really funny is the way that
everybody is introduced to our work is,
is the same way,
but it's the way that you wouldn't
expect.
So most people,
I think Jordan originally saw you in a
confrontation with somebody over Trans
Gender Pronouns.
Right?
And that's how most people began to
engage and then suddenly you are getting
500,000
views on discussions of biblical stories
from Genesis,
which yeah,
I mean,
let's be frank if,
if,
if the first thing never happens,
those things at 5,000
views,
right?
Then the same thing is true for me,
The way that I originally kind of drew
public attention was because I was on
piers Morgan's show,
I shall act him on his show.
And so all of a sudden people were now
listening to hour long lectures about,
about,
you know,
my,
my ideas on philosophy and principles of
the founding fathers.
They came for the scandal and stayed for
the content.
And that's,
and that's,
I think the advantage that it takes a
particular skill set for everyone in
this space to be able to do that.
But that's,
that's the beauty of the,
of the youtube moment and over the
Internet moment is that people are
engaging in the news level.
If you just watch any cable news
channel,
the new cycle is about 30 seconds long.
Then the repeat the headlines again.
Uh,
and so that's the level at which we
consume,
but if you see every sees the flash
point for you or the flash point for me
or the flashpoint for Sam with Ben
Affleck and one of the flash point for
you with number many of them for you.
And then they and then they want more
and it's the introduction of the,
it's basically the gateway drug.
Like there's a 32nd video that's the
gateway drug to these hour long lectures
about deeper principles and people and
the reason that the.
And the question is why those
flashpoints flash.
And I think the because what makes those
different,
what makes it that people want to see
that and then they go,
okay,
now I want to see the rest of their
content and start streaming tons of
videos from these folks.
Kathy Newman video is a good example.
So let's get to that in one second.
I want,
I just want to lead that is,
is just that I think it's incongruent.
They see something different and if you
notice a difference in the society on
any level,
then you are automatically a pariah and
an outlier and we all know deep down
that there are distinctions and
differences to be made logically
between.
I'm not even talking about groups of
people ethnically,
you know,
for some odd reason.
I'm talking about just logical
distinctions between modes of thought
and logical distinctions between,
uh,
between certain policies.
And if you,
if you are willing to draw distinctions
instead of just saying that we have to
exist in this morass of identity
politics,
that's a,
it's a flash in the darkness and people
gravitate toward the light
partly because the problem with the
problem with rel relativism,
let's say,
let's say that that did produce a
radical state of equality.
Well,
the problem with that is that there's no
up and the problem with there being no
opposite,
there's no hope.
And the problem with that is that people
actually live on hope.
Yes.
So if you flatten out the value
structure so that there is no
qualitative differentiation between
things,
then there's nothing to do.
So that's just not helpful.
And so then you can tell people,
look,
make no mistake about it,
there is down.
That's hell,
that's Auschwitz.
That's the gulags like that's down,
that exists,
that exists in your own family.
You can create that with no problem.
And because there's a down like that,
there's also an APP and that APP is
worth aiming at.
Even though it differentiates people as
they climb towards it.
It's still,
without that,
you can't have the purpose in your life
that gives it meaning and nobility in
the face of suffering.
Well that's a no,
that's interesting because that's why I
sort of think it's almost like we're all
Frankenstein's monster in a weird way.
If the.
If the mainstream media had been dealing
honestly with the issues of the day,
whatever they are,
identity politics are postmodernism or
just the general political discussion,
then I don't think people would react to
you guys the way that they do because
they didn't do their job.
But really quickly,
[inaudible] you hit these.
So your more I think were three moments
and you already hit them.
But just for people that are,
that aren't falling,
all this you on piers Morgan basically
bashing him endlessly with facts over
feelings about guns was one where it was
like this guy from the Internet just
beat this CNN per person.
How did that happen?
And then I think the one that changed me
more than anything else,
everyone knows this already with Sam
Harris on real time with,
with athletic,
and they got into this stuff about,
about the difference between Muslims and
Islam.
I didn't even know who sam was.
I see this mild mannered neuroscientists
in a nice suit commonly talking about
Pew statistics.
Next thing you know,
he's gross and racist.
But,
but this is a good segue to yours
because I think yours is the third one
and the way that this is just two or
three weeks ago,
uh,
you were on with Kathy Newman on it's
Canada channel for UK,
UK channel for sorry.
And there is,
I mean,
everyone that's watching this has
probably seen this already.
If you haven't,
you should go watch it.
But,
but in effect,
basically she tried to make an argument
that you have heard a good Julian Times
before,
but why does your right to free speech
supersede a trans person's right to feel
okay with themselves or something.
Even the way she phrased the question
was a little confused and conflated,
but.
But the reaction to it,
it was your,
your answer was great,
but it was the reaction to regular
people watching at home that we're
going,
this is nonsense.
This is just abject.
No,
the only thing that's to make it viral
is the fact that she recognized in the
moment to what she was saying moment
where you could see the light go on
briefly and she just went,
wait,
what did I just say?
And there was no escape.
It was pretty.
It was pretty grand.
Yeah.
Well,
the funny thing about her argument is
that it's Pr was predicated on the idea
that somehow people have a right to be
comfortable.
It's like that's just not a right you
have in life all the things you can say
that you don't have a right to in life.
Being comfortable is number one is you
can offend me right now,
so the thing is is if you,
if you're right to be comfortable,
trumps my right to talk,
then I don't get to talk ever because
I'm going to say things.
If I'm actually talking,
If they're,
if they're profound things,
if they're contentious,
things are truthful things,
I'm going to say things that if they
don't disturb you are going to disturb
you and if they don't disturb you,
there's someone that's going to be
disturbed about them.
So what's the answer to that?
Everyone can be comfortable in the
silence,
but that doesn't also doesn't work
because then we can't exchange ideas.
We're not comfortable in the silence.
We're isolated and Dan didn't the
silence,
so it's a completely incoherent
perspective,
but what does that tell you about just
the way mainstream media operates?
Because if you even,
even just in this last week when I've
read some of the pieces about you that I
think are so dishonesty attacking the
way you do things or even there was an
article about you and it was like Ben
Shapiro is the cool kids philosopher or
something,
something like that.
Yeah.
And it was like,
well wait a minute.
When did the cool kid be the smart
Orthodox Jew?
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
how did,
how does that.
But think about that.
And then you've talked,
you've talked about the shit that you
went through when you were growing up
and all that stuff and you don't want to
play the regularly,
but I can't imagine exactly the same.
Just like small and noisy,
bad combat,
man.
I could have taken care of both of you.
I always say I was right on the middle
of sort of like loser and cool.
So like I actually did believe the kids
below me,
but I was bullied by the guys that were.
I was right there.
And maybe that maybe that keeps the
world in balance.
There you go.
But this idea that when they write the
article,
it's the cool kids will ask her even
though obviously you didn't grow up as
the cool kid or James Demore is a great
one where they write articles about him
and they'll say the,
the tech Bro.
And it's like if you both have met James
Moore,
he's the shyest.
Quietest decent.
You almost literally have to drag
sentences.
Yeah.
But,
but he's.
But a spine of steel though.
It's really something.
Yeah.
Fearless.
Despite what his disposition may
actually be.
But.
But what do you make of that?
The way that they try to frame it.
So they're already trying to undercut,
you know what I mean before it,
before you even say it
is your model.
But I think that they're trying to
impose their own order on the chaos.
It's just the wrong frame.
So that's what happened in the channel
for interview and it's,
it's sort of,
I was thinking about the model that you
were describing with regards to your
position on the iceberg is that Kathy
had staked out a position on the iceberg
and I had staked one out that was way
lower,
way lower and what happened was she kept
questioning me at her level of analysis
and that just wasn't working because
that wasn't the level of analysis at
which I'm playing.
Well,
and I'm also not playing,
although I'm trying to play,
you know what I mean,
because it's a little bit.
But yeah,
I mean I was like wrestling,
you had a lower base of gravity and,
and I think that that gave you an
advantage and that's partly.
I wasn't trying to win the interview.
Right.
You know,
like I and I don't try to win
interviews.
I'd try to go to an interview and have a
talk and have a discussion and see how
it goes.
And I don't have an agenda except to not
make a catastrophic mistake,
but that's agenda number one.
Don't say anything.
Unforgivably stupid.
Yeah.
I think that's the other thing that,
that makes all of this unique is that if
you actually meet any.
I mean we've all met each other in the
circle now because it's really funny how
life works that way.
These circles are so small,
but we tell each other and we actually
talk with each other and all this.
That's what I'm saying.
They're forcing us together.
It's not even that we're seeking it,
but it's also that we all have a
certain.
There's a certain baseline personality
that we all have and that is we enjoy
the discussion.
We actually enjoyed the exchange of
ideas and so when you're on with Kathy
Newman and she says stuff that like
what,
what you were getting from the right
when the lot was how to even stand this.
How do you understand this interview?
Right?
How can you get through half an hour of
this and you've done it and I've done it
too.
And the answer is because I sort of
enjoy it.
I mean this is what you do for a living.
Right?
So the idea that I don't enjoy having
conversations,
even with people who don't get it,
it's not enjoyable having your views
radically mischaracterized as he as
Kathy Newman was trying to do to you.
That's irritating,
but I was so over the top.
It was hardly even irritated.
It's mostly kept thinking,
well,
I don't know who you're talking to you,
but it isn't me.
Right?
Exactly,
exactly.
And so because of,
because of that,
that's the most infuriating thing to
people on,
on the hardcore left and in the media,
because if they can't fit you into that
frame,
it's what you were saying before the
show started and if they can't fit you
into this preconceived notion of Russian
nesting doll that they've got for you.
If you.
If you don't fit in there,
then they can't do anything with you.
And if you're an open minded person who
actually likes to hear exchange of ideas
and you're willing to admit that there's
a piece of evidence you may not have
considered yet,
it's almost impossible to be caught off
guard.
But these people refuse to acknowledge
that there's evidence they haven't
considered yet.
Or do they just throw away the evidence?
Like if I brought you a piece of
evidence that country that can do roll
deed say,
okay,
that either fits in my worldview or it
doesn't if it doesn't,
but it's a real piece of evidence.
Here's how I have to kind of shape and
changed my world view in order to
accommodate that piece of evidence.
And I think that's what smart and decent
people do.
But at the media is not in that role.
I think that's where Joe show was
successful is because,
you know,
he's not a classical intellectual.
He talks about ideas a lot.
But the thing about joe is he's actually
curious.
He,
when he asks a question and he'd like to
know the answer,
you know,
and it's not so that he can demonstrate
that he's right.
But yeah,
if this viewpoint,
so obviously like everyone does because
you have to have a viewpoint,
but he does ask the questions he'd like
to know the answers to and that's that
and youtube seems to reward that,
so hooray for them when it's also the
fact that it's a longer forum,
a longer span forum is also a nontrivial
advantage because people can take the
time to riddick into something.
I didn't think a lot about what makes
all of these various people have such
different stripes successful and what I
realized is that so much of it is just
like in any movie,
it was the reason you watch a movie is
because you know where the movie's going
to end.
It's going to end with the movie,
go turning off the screen and then
you're going to leave the theater.
Right?
The every movie ends the same way,
but it's you're there for the journey.
And so when you watch your show,
Dave,
and you're actually trying to pursue
things and take people along your
thought journey and when you watch your
lectures on the Bible and you're
tracking them along a journey,
a journey of exploration and certainly
with Joseph,
joe or Joe is taking you for three hours
through his thought process,
asking questions and going somewhere and
even when I'm doing my political show,
my idea is here I'm going to lay out all
the evidence and then try and piece it
together so that we get to a conclusion
together and you can disagree with any
step I take along that way,
but here's the journey that we're going
go on so you can follow along with me.
I think what the media do is they just
go straight from the beginning of the
movie to the end of the movie with no
journey and they just go,
okay,
here's the Intro,
right?
Luke Skywalker is on a planet by himself
and then you just go straight to the
Millennium Falcon flying where you're
like,
what?
Just what happened in the middle there
that why we're we're we then,
or let's say your,
your moment with Kathy,
that we're sort of the glitch in the
system now.
Like to me that were the undecidable in
postmodern terms there.
There you go.
That's it.
That,
that,
that's a glitch.
Like if we were watching the matrix,
that's the glitch that you got to the,
to the wasn't on Youtube.
This was on real television.
Not that that even matters more than
this because I think this is the real
thing now.
But you caused the glitch.
That's
what you did.
You caused the glitch and her.
She actually couldn't come up with words
after,
but you actually was actually a glitch
in the system that then.
Yeah,
well that was aided.
Everything else that you're doing isn't
imposed narrative and I mean,
part of that's a consequence of the
pathology of the medium,
I would say is that one of the things
that's really like I stopped watching
televised news like 25 years ago,
but one of the things that made me stop
was my realization that the newscasters
would show a politician.
Right.
And then they'd give him like his 10
seconds or heard her 10 seconds to say
something.
Then they'd fade out the audio.
Then the newscaster would tell you what
the person said and what it meant.
And I thought,
oh,
that's not so good.
That's,
that's there's something gone,
gone horribly wrong there.
And I think that's.
It's become more and more like that over
the last 30 years.
Partly I think that's because journalism
itself,
classic journalism is degenerating.
It's becoming a more and more desperate
game for,
for smaller and smaller stakes.
But Youtube offers something that,
that,
that the traditional broadcasters just
can't offer.
And that's weirdly enough for something
that started out with cute cat videos.
It's actual depth and the capacity to
have like a three hour conversation
turns out people actually like that.
But that's why I think that youtube are
particularly interesting cases because I
view you as sort of like a pure
political beast.
And yet you've.
Because of all of this,
you now talk about religion.
I think more than probably you
inherently want to perhaps or all of
these other things.
And you as a clinical psychologist.
But that's where you really started and
now you end up talking about politics
all the time.
So again,
this is why we all sort of got forced
into this,
into this space.
In the end,
we ended up in the same framework to the
ancient Greeks ended up in,
right?
They would all write a book on ethics
and they'd write one on politics and
then he would write one on,
on the pilot and it all comes together.
I mean if there is no such thing as
apolitical,
but by the same token,
there's no such thing as a ethical
right.
I mean if you're,
if you,
if you are operating in the sphere of
politics,
you are going to end up.
If you dig deep enough in the same
waters that Jordan is used to being.
And if Jordan elevates,
you know,
up on that chain far enough,
he's going to end up in these sphere
where I'm used to operating.
Which is why there are videos of you
talking to transgender people about
about Pronoun use a.
What happened
to me,
I think was that like I was operating at
a,
let's call it a psychological level or a
level of,
of,
of archetypal story essentially,
and then the political intervened in
that and said,
I'm going to interfere with your freedom
of speech.
It's like,
no,
that's not happening.
I know where that goes.
Well,
and then of course one of the scandals
that emerged out of that this year was
the scandal of Lindsay Shepherd at
Wilfrid laurier university,
which was the biggest scandal that ever
hit a Canadian university,
and it was like,
how do I,
in my most pessimistic prognostications
about the consequences of bill
[inaudible].
I didn't envision the inquisition of
Lindsay Shepherd and so thank you very
much.
Postmodernists for making that manifest.
So clearly is in the room.
So if you.
Can you tell that story?
Well,
there was a teaching.
They a great episode on the Rubin
Report.
You should.
Yeah.
Well she's quite the creature.
She's a.
They picked what?
They messed with the wrong girl when
they went after her,
but she was in the communications
department at Wilfrid laurier university
in Canada,
and she had the temerity to show a five
minute clip of me debating the
biological reality of gender,
let's say with a professor,
Nicolas,
Matt,
who famously claimed that there were no
biological differences between men and
women and that was the scientific
consensus for the last four decades.
She showed a five minute clip to her
class while and hypothetically someone
complained,
although it turned out that no one
really did and that was brought to the
attention of her professors and to an
administrator named Andrea Joel who was
basically hired as a,
you know,
a as an inquisition I would say by the
university under legislative pressure.
And they raked her over the coals for an
hour and she taped it and she made it
public and it's,
it,
it was a tape in which they compared.
They said that playing a,
a video of me debating pronouns was
neutrally because she said she did it
neutrally and there's no reason to
disbelieve her.
Was tantamount to playing a video by
Hitler neutrally or Milo Yiannopoulos
has been there.
The radical leftists are so clueless
that they can't even get their insults
right.
So I'm not Milo Yiannopoulos or Hitler.
Sorry.
It's one or the other and I've been in
this building.
This building has some people at it.
Yeah,
I mean even right now we know that
someone's going to write about this and
write that this was the gathering of the
alt right and all that other nonsense,
but in a weird way,
do we owe the potter.
Postmodern is some thanks then because
if you think about it,
they took,
they forced someone like Lindsay to be
public now and I and I think she's
wonderful as you know,
just the tremendous intellect and Bret
Weinstein,
right?
Like all the,
all of these people,
you guys,
me,
I mean everyone out of the James Damore.
I mean he only is someone now with
influence because they forced him to
address these issues.
So in an odd way we owed them.
I mean,
for,
for all the complaining that we might do
about these people,
we owe them because they've sharpened
not only,
they've not only sharpened us
intellectually,
but I think they've allowed all these
other people to wake up.
Monitors had a point like the point is
is that the world is susceptible to a
near infinite number of interpretations
that happens to be true.
That's why developing artificial
intelligence,
especially perceptual systems,
has turned out to be so difficult.
It's very,
very difficult to perceive the world
because you can categorize it in
literally in a near infinite number of
ways.
Okay,
and then the next plane was.
Well,
it's very difficult to rank order those
ways in terms of quality.
It's like,
yeah,
that is very difficult,
but then they pushed it too far.
Therefore,
there are no qualitative distinctions
between loads of interpretation.
It's interpretation all the way down.
It's like,
no,
no
good,
good point.
Hard to disagree with,
but fundamentally wrong.
There's a finite set of viable
interpretations.
Well,
the layman's term for that would be that
some things are real,
right?
I mean is that the simplest way to say
it?
There are some things that actually are
real.
I think that's,
that's,
that's one objection.
Another objection is there are some
modes of being that lead you to
perdition very,
very rapidly and that's.
And that isn't somewhere being human
that you actually want to go.
So there's the material reality that's
outside the interpretive framework,
you know,
but then there's an ethical reality that
isn't material and the same simple
sense,
but there's an ethical reality that's
also not merely a matter of
interpretation.
I mean,
the best example of that I know is Jaak
Panksepp,
Jaak Panksepp work with rats.
I mean there's lots of models of this
and the animal kingdom,
but that this one is particularly good.
So juvenile rats like to wrestle.
So if you pair two wraps together,
two males,
because they particularly liked to
wrestle and one of them's 10 percent
bigger than the other one with the 10
percent weight advantage can pin the
little one can consistently.
Okay,
so you say you pair them once,
they'll work to do this because they
enjoy it.
The big one pins,
he wins.
Now he's the dominant rap.
You think?
Well,
there's dominance among rats.
Yeah,
except that isn't how it works because
rats in the wild live in social groups
and they'll play with each other,
continually cross many games.
So then let's say you pair the two
routes together constantly.
Okay.
After the first bout the little rat,
the loser has to invite the big route to
play.
That's the rule.
So he does his little play and the big
rep thinks,
yeah,
okay.
I'll play.
If you pair them repeatedly,
unless the big rat lets the little rat
win 30 percent of the time the little
rat will start playing with them.
I read that.
It just blew me away.
I thought,
wow,
look at that in rats,
which have been used as a model for
human behavior for psychologists for
like 100 years in rats.
There's an emergent ethic of fairplay
that emerges across iterated games.
It's like,
really?
It's mindboggling,
so we could use that.
That would be an example of like when
I'm playing basketball with my eight
year old nephew,
I occasionally let him live because I
want to because he needs that reward
going if I just beat him mercilessly and
if you're good,
you let him.
When when he does something particularly
spectacular,
right?
You push them.
There's this thing called the zone of
proximal development and it turns out
that adults speak to children naturally
at a level.
It's slightly above their level of
comprehension,
so that's the meaning zone essentially,
and so you keep the kid there because
the kid can talk but also learn at the
same time and if you're really playing
well with your eight year old nephew,
you're gonna let him win when he's
pushing himself a little harder than you
normally would and you think,
well that's he is winning when he's
doing that and so you want to set up the
game to reward it,
and that's an ethic that transcends mere
interpretation.
It's not.
It doesn't only apply to human beings.
It applies.
And Frans de Waal who studied
chimpanzee's,
he's found quite clearly that it isn't
the most tyrannical chimp who stays on
top because the chimp tyrant who has no
friends who does know mutual grooming,
who's not
reciprocal,
it's like he has an off day and two of
his enemies tear him to pieces.
So the tyrant champ sits atop a very
unstable hierarchy.
And so I've thought to,
in the West,
we don't have dominance hierarchies,
we have competence hierarchies and those
are completely different and you have to
be a good player,
have iterated games to maintain your
position in a competence hierarchy.
And that's the beginnings of a
discussion about something like a
fundamental ethic.
So That's interesting.
I think I can segue this too,
a little bit of the way that some of the
media deals with you is that you,
because you are fact based,
you talk fast,
you don't care.
I mean you genuinely don't care about
people's feelings.
I know you pretty well now you don't
that they don't.
Maybe your wife,
but they don't know how to respond to
that then because they're used to
dealing in a realm that is all about
that.
So now you come out and you're like,
no,
no.
This is the way it is.
I'll debate you,
but you're not gonna beat me just
because you happen to be gay or a woman
or whatever else it is,
and I think actually now that's a lot of
the reason of your your surge.
I think that most people at root level
don't actually want to think of
themselves as their group identity
first.
I think most people would want to be
respected on an individual level and so
when I say in order for you to be
respected on an individual level,
that means that I'm not going to respect
you on the group level.
Meaning I'm not your group.
Identity doesn't mean anything to me.
Your individual identity means
everything to me,
but your group identity means nothing to
me.
And when I say individual identity,
I don't mean how you identify,
you know,
in terms of race or gender.
I mean,
in terms of your thoughts,
are your thoughts interesting,
are they right,
are they wrong,
and they're either right or they're
wrong and they're interesting or they're
not,
and that doesn't change based on who's
saying it and if we could all get there,
I think that that's what people find
appealing is that if you can get there,
then you can actually have a discussion
about ideas.
If not,
then you're just going to retreat into
your identity and there's no way for me
to have a discussion with you.
I mean I just had a talk at Yukon and
one of the students got up and was
talking about abortion.
Then she said,
you know,
I,
I would never have an abortion,
but you as a white privileged male,
how could you talk about abortion?
And I said,
because right is right and wrong is
wrong.
Regardless of whether I am a white
privileged male.
I mean that's the basis for western
civilization.
Otherwise we can't have.
We can't have a conversation.
Then what happens if we can't have a
conversation across groups and we just
fight for dominance.
That's exactly well that,
and that's the postmodern worldview.
That's all we're doing.
It's like,
fine,
but like you're,
you're,
you're opening the door to the radical
right wingers because they're going to
come in and say,
okay,
no problem.
We'll play identity politics,
but I'm not losing.
How's that?
Right.
Well,
that isn't the way you're supposed to
play.
You're supposed to be guilty.
It's like,
no,
sorry,
I'm not going to be guilty.
I'm just going to be dominant.
Exactly.
This is the danger of the actual
outright because with the own right is
reactionary identity,
politics,
movements and left doesn't want to
acknowledge its own role in helping to
drive the,
the emergence of,
of a reaction or identity politics
movement,
which by the way,
I find despicable because I think all
identity politics,
movements,
artists,
exactly
what I think,
right or left.
I did a year of shows on if the left
doesn't clean them when I was still
saying I'm on the left.
If we don't clean up our house,
what is going to happen and look what
has happened.
So shifting slightly a little bit,
I thought this would be interesting.
Is there a criticism,
actually I'll start with you for using
this one.
Is there a criticism of you that you
think is the most legit?
No criticism of me?
You know,
I,
I think that
the,
the criticism of me that I think is
legit is one that I think is probably
common to most people,
which is I,
I tend to fall into confirmation bias,
which is true for everybody.
Uh,
so,
you know,
I think that,
but it,
you know,
when you're in the political realm,
the easiest thing to do is to find
evidence that supports your position and
Cherry pick the evidence in order to
support that position.
And so if the idea is that I tend to do
that,
I try to fight that,
but I'll acknowledge that that's a flaw,
that I have a,
that you know,
when you're,
when you're invested in a political
fight,
that the easy that,
that your easiest mode of confrontation
is to find stuff that supports what you
already think as opposed to taking in
all of the available evidence and then
shifting every point as we were talking
about before,
uh,
toward the,
toward the right position.
Uh,
it's because I think it is a weakness.
It's something that I,
that I tried to fight as often as
possible.
And uh,
I tried to make provision for that.
So,
so before I ask you yours,
um,
what,
what do I think,
what do you,
what do you think,
what do you think is wrong in the band?
And B,
what do you think is psychologically the
best way to deal with that?
To be,
to be aware,
right?
You're being aware of what your issues,
limitations are,
what your biases might be,
psychologically,
what's the best way to
yourself with competent people who,
who have their areas of expertise that
aren't yours and to listen to them,
you know,
and that's.
That's helped me over the last 15 months
because I've had about 10 people around
me,
five of them are family members,
about five of them were friends who were
extraordinarily competent people and
they go over what I've been doing and
they don't pull any punches.
This feelings thing,
this is something I'd like to spring to
your defense about because the rule if
you don't have an ethic is don't hurt
anyone's feelings.
It's like,
okay,
but which feelings do you mean?
What do you mean?
Like this seconds,
feelings or do you mean the person's
wellbeing across a year?
Because lots of times when you're having
a firm discussion with someone that
upsets them in the present.
This happens with children all the time,
is you're.
You're not taking stock of their
feelings at the moment except insofar as
you have to because you want to help
prevent them from cascading into
catastrophe.
For the rest of their life,
it's like,
well,
I'm going to discipline you,
right and I'm going to tell you why you
were wrong.
We're going to have a hard conversation
because if you keep that up,
your life is going to be a never ending
stream of misery.
Well,
that's not cruel and so,
but because people don't see the ethic
of iterated games,
let's say something like that.
They say,
well,
you just shouldn't hurt anybody's
feelings in the moment.
It's like,
no.
Well,
this is why I think both you and I
object to the whole idea of the pleasure
pain matrix being the,
the,
the thing that matters
in terms of human happiness and because
the bottom line is that you may be
experiencing a good deal of pain right
now,
but that's going to lead to a more
fulfilled life.
That's the utility of sacrifice because
everyone knows that give up something
now in a rather painful way and you may
benefit in the future.
Yeah,
the pain,
the pain pleasures ethic doesn't work
because of the problem of time.
Exactly on time and other people.
That's another reason that doesn't work.
So it's,
yeah,
you need a way more sophisticated
solution to that.
So.
So now let's turn that question to you.
What do you think is the most legit
criticism that you see?
Because I see a lot of blue check,
you know,
twitter,
people with 5,000
followers just attacking.
Yeah.
Very rarely about your idea though.
They'll just make up something.
Jordan Peterson says dogs are blue and
green,
uh,
at somebody.
Somebody basically did that and I
invited him on the show to talk to you.
And then of course he disappeared for I
would say I have some problem with mood
regulation,
you know?
And so sometimes I'm more irritable than
I should be.
Sometimes I'm more,
I'm,
I come across.
Well,
no,
I probably am more angry than is optimal
in the circumstance,
you know,
I mean,
one of the rules of English common law
for example,
is that you're more or less allowed to
defend yourself with minimum necessary
force.
And I've had to practice and practice
and practice to use the minimum
necessary for if you really want to hit
him right now.
Like that is the temptation.
I mean,
I think we all struggle with that.
I mean there's certain times or somebody
says something to say,
Oh,
I just,
oh,
I mean it's there,
there's certain questions that get asked
and it's just a slow pitch softball
right down the center of the plate.
It's like,
do I need to,
do I need to hit this soft ball as hard
as I possibly can,
especially rough if you have a sense of
humor too.
But,
but it's,
it's really useful.
And I have learned this.
It's really useful to not defend
yourself to vociferously,
which is weird because you'd think,
well you have the right to defend
yourself.
Like no all,
no holds barred.
It's like,
no,
actually doesn't work that way,
that you have to defend yourself with
minimal necessary force.
And I think I managed that in the
channel for interview,
for Shank.
Go on.
Believe me.
People have been talking to me about
that nonstop for 15 months and I'm
listening and it wouldn't work as well
if he hadn't done that or if he just
shall actor.
If he just gotten right at her and said,
what you are saying is so stupid for
these five reasons,
it would.
It would have been bad I think.
I think the fact that you sat there and
he just said,
no,
you're asking good questions and you
know the fact that you're asking good
questions demonstrates the invalidity of
your entire field.
That that was much more effective.
Right.
Well,
and that's one of the things I've been
meditating on for the last years.
There's a line in the new testament
says,
resist not evil.
I think,
okay,
what?
Okay,
what the hell you're supposed to apply.
It's like because it's really a
difficult thing to figure out.
You really mean that you don't resist
evil.
Well,
there's a couple of problems is if you
punch back then you have a fight.
Well,
but you can't just not defend yourself
like weekly.
You can't be weak and not defend
yourself,
but you can be strong and defend
yourself minimally,
and that's a real art.
Like that's,
that's the essence of sophistication.
I would say.
Like I'm not,
you know,
I come from kind of a rough place.
I'm coming from northern Alberta.
I come from the frontier,
you know,
and my town was scraped out of the
bloody prairie 50 years before people
move before,
before I lived there.
And so,
uh,
it's,
it's been an,
it's been a continual challenge to
adjust my sophistication to the level of
challenge and I've,
I'm trying to do that.
Do you think that.
I don't always manage it.
Yeah.
So to that point,
do you think that we sometimes actually
at a deep level use identity politics
against ourselves in,
in this regard?
So you're sitting across from Kathy,
she's female at some level.
Do you think you may be moderated it
because of that?
Because had it been a male and you talk
about this often,
that we have to act differently towards
males and females and there's a
physical.
There's physical reasons for that and
biological reasons for that,
but that had she been a male,
say,
say the same exact age from you,
from Alberta and all of that,
that perhaps your response might have
been a little more forceful even though
you're.
We're all agreeing your response was
done correctly and even handedly.
Yeah.
Well,
I.
it's hard to say,
but probably yes.
That's interesting.
Well,
because you like,
I can't.
I don't think that you can say that you
fight with a woman the same way that you
fight with a man.
That doesn't mean you can't fight with a
woman.
Doesn't mean you shouldn't,
but I don't think the rules are the
same.
Now,
why are the rules different?
Well,
some of the rules are,
there's a physical limit.
It's much more stringent,
right?
I mean there's a level of hinting out
physical threat that you can bring to
bear in a conversation between men that
you cannot bring to bear in a
conversation with a woman.
So,
and the mechanics of that are very,
very subtle and difficult and it's
especially challenging in an
intellectual discussion because an
intellectual discussion is a kind of war
and it isn't obvious how men and women
should go to war with one another.
We don't know.
We don't know how to sort that out.
You.
My sense has been on the panels that
I've done is that I definitely have to
pull my punches.
If I'm on a panel with women,
that doesn't mean that I don't.
It doesn't mean that it's any less
challenging intellectually,
but the strategy and the attitude has to
be different.
It's much more likely that you'll be
seen as a bully if you bring the same
force to bear on a female opponent as
you would on a male opponent.
Yeah.
So I'm wondering if Hillary Clinton is a
perfect example of this in the political
sphere.
You,
Rebecca [inaudible] and hilary was
running for Senate in New York and
riskalyze.
Lazio walk across the stage and asked
her to sign a piece of paper and like
them
headlines where they basically assaulted
her.
Right?
Or if Rick Lazio had walked across stage
another man,
it's said sentence piece of paper,
but like,
what a tough guy look at that he's
willing to stand up to him.
So I suspect in that case your answer to
this question is no.
You would treat people the same if,
if Piers Morgan that night had been
female,
you would have done the exact same.
Well,
I mean I was,
I was actually relatively polite to
peers.
So it's uh,
it's,
it,
to me,
it's,
I try to be as polite as possible unless
the person is being very impolite,
in which case I'm happy to go employed.
So I,
I tried to,
instead of trying to gauge sort of the,
uh,
we're doing the same thing just from
different directions instead of trying
to determine how I engage with the
person by all of the various,
you know,
I,
I let them take the first punch.
Basically you take the first step in the
waltz and then I'll respond in kind.
So if you,
if you wanna if you wanna act polite,
that I'm happy to act polite with you
and I'm happy to have a nice cordial
conversation.
If you want to get nasty then we'll get
nasty and we'll do that.
And I prep for interviews.
So I'm happy if you want to go into
mine,
I'm happy to go to the mind.
We can do that.
Yeah.
So I want to circle back to something
related to religion that we,
that I wanted to get to earlier,
but we're,
we're doing a lot here.
Um,
do you think there's any difference or
do you both think there's any
difference?
Ben's belief in Ben's Jewish and your
belief is Christian comes from the
Christian tradition.
Yeah.
Does that matter at hall?
Whatever differences there are in that
little place where you're both saying,
you know,
we see the reasons why our morals and
ethics and all that come from this
world.
So acknowledging,
uh,
you know,
the,
the real world and biology and all of
those things,
whatever differences you may have,
which I don't even know that we,
that any of the three of us know what
those differences are.
Do they even matter?
They might.
All right.
That would be a lovely.
I'd love to figure out if there are,
if there are.
I mean it depends.
For me,
it depends on the brand of religion that
a person is,
is espousing.
So,
so let's just,
let's just do this with youtube.
I mean,
so my,
my feeling,
and I'm writing a book on this right now
actually,
so I,
I,
there are certain principles that
obviously under the Christianity that
are from the Judaic tradition and that
clearly the first manifestation of the
prophetic tradition.
Exactly.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's essentially an attempt to merge
Jerusalem with Athens is,
is I think the,
the book of John is the most obvious
example of using the logo says as sort
of the unifying feature and writing the
whole thing in Greek.
Right?
I mean that was not the,
the,
the Lingua Franca of the time.
That was not what people were speaking,
excepted and educated circles.
So I'm all the Judaic principles,
things like a god involved in history,
a god who cares about individuals,
uh,
the notion that you have a choice
between good and evil,
so choose good,
uh,
and that and so that you will live long
on the earth,
right?
The,
all these things were taken forward into
Christianity.
The major distinctions in terms of,
of Christianity versus Judaism are the
idea that,
and again,
it depends on your interpretation of
Christianity.
Early Christianity sort of suggested
that history had ended with Christ and
then in later kind of iterations of
Christianity that was moved beyond,
right?
It wasn't that history had ended,
it was that Christ come back when
history had reached its logical
progression.
The progression of history didn't end,
but original messianism was,
this is the Messiah were done,
right?
History is over.
It was a millennialist religion.
It depends on.
Every few people think that that's
right.
So this is why I'm trying to
distinguish,
you know,
brands of Christianity,
because obviously there are serious
differences even in basic root level
between Catholicism and calvinism.
And lutheranism and all these things
have different iterations.
So you know,
my very strong belief in freewill and my
actual building of a moral system in
Judaism is building moral system on the
notion of free will obviously runs
directly counter to,
for example,
calvinism.
Calvinism suggest that freewill is a,
is a miracle and there's no basis for it
and uh,
that God grants you grace based on what
he wants to do.
So it depends on the brand of
Christianity.
But I think that overall the conflict
between Christianity and Judaism in
large measure is,
especially in the early conflict,
was political rather than ideological
and a lot of ways it was a new religion
attempting to establish its own footing
and was angry that,
that Jews would not join this new
religion and leave behind tradition.
I think that there are certain ways in
which Christianity,
you know,
like for example,
the,
the main distinction between
Christianity,
Judaism,
the people usually make is that
Christianity is a great space.
Religion and Judaism is a religion.
Meaning the Judaism says you sort of
earn your way into heaven,
right?
You earn your way toward a better life,
uh,
and,
and Christianity says,
if you believe right,
I am the way,
the truth and the life.
If you believe,
then you're good.
But the truth is that Christianity sort
of back doors,
the,
the Judaic view by saying,
if you really do believe,
then you're going to act in these
particular ways to demonstrate your.
There's this weird paradoxical
relationship between the idea of belief
in Christianity,
the belief that that Christ came to save
everyone from their sins and that all
you have to do is admit that and you're
redeemed.
Like there's symbolic truth to that.
That would take a long time to unpack,
but there's also an injunction goes
along with that to imitate Christ in
your life.
Exactly.
I feel like a lot of these distinctions
are almost,
some of them are almost a little false.
I mean,
meaning that they're,
they're either a Christian misreads of
Judaism or Jewish misreads of,
of Christianity,
and that when you get to the root of it,
I mean,
this is what my mom says,
that there are significant differences
between Judaism and Christianity,
but his view of Christianity from the
Jewish historical point of view is that
Judaism was never bound to convert
billions of people around the world,
but Christianity was specifically
because we have a lot of crap we got to
do.
I mean Jews have,
we have 613 commandments,
you know,
we gotta we have to keep kosher.
We have to do all of these things.
I appreciate you doing a lot of them for
me.
Yeah,
no problem.
And taking care of it.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll transfer over the point.
I'll give you one of my afterlife
exactly.
But uh,
but I think that Christianity ends up
doing a lot of those same things that,
you know,
there were supposed to be start
distinctions just under a different
guise.
So when it comes to the,
this is why in the modern world when the
discrimination between from Christians
toward Jews largely has,
has ended,
I think that what you're seeing is this
tremendous confluence between
particularly orthodox Jews and observant
Christians on matters,
on matters of values,
uh,
because once Christianity and in the
late 20th century,
in the Mid Twentieth Century in America
more broadly with Christianity,
because American Christianity is very
different than European Christianity,
once,
once there was an idea that Jews were
not the enemy to be converted,
but we're,
maybe you still want to convert me,
but we're not going to come at you with
a knife.
We're going to come at you with the book
and that we share a common framework for
how the world is supposed to work.
You may not agree with the second half
of the book.
Right?
And then I think that that's,
that's created a pretty good working
relationship with [inaudible].
This is why I'm struggling to come up
with what are the significant
differences.
And so I need,
I need a Christian to tell me what is
the significant difference.
I can argue with that question because I
know my own religion better than I know
Marshall question is being,
I don't know if the rule that the state
plays in Judaism and Christianity is the
same because I'm not sure what to make
of the.
Like what I would say is the Jews put a
tremendous amount of emphasis on the
state as a mechanism for salvation,
something like that.
That might be the symbolic idea that
underlies the establishment of Israel
and I would say that in Christianity and
the nation,
or you mean like the government,
I mean the nation,
but then it gets tangled up with the
government.
Right?
So,
so,
so.
Right.
This is a distinction that Jay,
that Christianity is a universal
universalistic religion,
right?
The idea is that it that in the Kingdom
of God,
everyone is Christian basically,
and Judaism is not in one sense,
but it is another which is that God
identifies a nation that he treasures as
his own and he has a special
relationship with that nation,
but Judaism is not exclusive.
This with regard to who gets into
heaven.
So there's this,
there's this basic idea in a in genesis
that there are commandments that are
given prior to the giving of the Torah,
right?
That there's the call,
the Sheva Mitzvah Day and off the seven
commandments that are given to the sons
of Noah,
meaning all mankind.
And these are things like no murder,
no idolatry,
no adultery.
They basically mirror a lot of the 10
commandments.
And so the idea in Judaism is that God,
it's almost like a priestly cased.
God chose this specific group of people
to be a light unto the nations by
demonstrating what a godly lifestyle
looks like.
If you dedicate every aspect of your
life to God.
And then he said to everybody else,
I know not everybody else is up to this
and I and in fact Judy's are supposed to
try and turn away conference,
but if you,
but you can still get into heaven.
The idea that we are trying to force
anyone into,
into being Jewish,
that that's not a thing.
So nationalism without version.
And think about that psychologically as
an attempt to both manage the
preservation of group identity.
So that would be culture or cultural
identity,
which has some utility and also to be
able to coexist with other things.
We're doing things in a different way
and again,
Judaism has had a long history of of it
just like every other religion of sort
of evolution on this stuff or like when
you're the push of the book of Joshua,
there's actual forest conversion that
happens in the book of Joshua,
but by the time you get to a mid,
early Christianity and midpoint Judaism,
right?
Because Judaism and Christianity,
then you're already talking about Jews
who are not looking to convert people.
They sort of want to live in their own
state.
They don't want to bother anyone else
for the most part a.
So the idea of like a tidal wave of
conquering Jews going out.
I mean,
even to think about it now is hilarious,
right?
Nobody thinks about it that way.
Except if you're a conspiratorial nutbag
inquisitions usually work the other way.
That's right.
So,
so any,
anything that you might've heard Ben
just say,
would any thing jive with the
fundamental belief that you have that
would cause a problem?
You know what I mean,
like coding a problem in I think in
society.
I think that one potential problem
that's that's worth discussing,
but it would take forever to discuss it
is the relative role of the individual
versus the state.
I mean you see this argued out in the
prophetic books and in the Old
Testament,
I mean there's the Jewish state and
it's.
It's sort of the central player in some
sense,
but there's clear evidence that it can
become corrupted,
can fall away,
and then a prophet who's an individual
has to step forward and re revivified
it.
Right,
and so there's tremendous emphasis on
the utility of the individual.
You see that in Judaea,
Judaism,
I would say overall it's,
it's a,
it's a very cohesive.
It,
it,
it promotes in group cohesion,
let's say,
but it also allows for individual
expression in a very interesting ways
because there's tremendous emphasis in
Jewish culture on learning and an
articulation and mastery of ideas,
and so that provides the space for the
individual to flourish.
With Christianity,
you see more of a move away,
I would say from the idea of the state
now that's not necessarily without its
troubles.
One of the things you pointed out was,
well,
as Christianity becomes more about the
individual,
the religion itself tends to fragment
like it did with protestantism until
just fragments right to the point where
every individual is their own church and
then you have no continuity and new
tradition and the Catholics were kind of
a bulwark against that.
But I do think that there's a discussion
to be had about the relative role of the
individual in redeeming the world,
let's say versus the state in redeeming
the world.
And I would say the Christians come down
more strongly on the side of the
individual and the Jews come down more
strongly on the side of the state now.
Like I'm willing to be corrected about
that because I've never actually been
able to have a discussion with anyone
about that.
So
I think there's some truth to that.
I mean,
I think the idea of,
you know,
in,
in Hebrew Ami,
I like the idea of the nation of Israel
being paramount and when you pray,
you pray and collective terms,
you don't pray in individual terms,
everything is,
is done in terms of inaccurate,
in terms of we praying as a group,
right?
You're supposed to pray in a minion.
So how do you square that away in your
own ways?
How do you square that away?
As soon as there's a lot of enjoyable,
there's a lot of play in the joints.
Meaning that,
uh,
so for example,
to take the most,
to take the most obvious example,
if you,
if you were talking about the power of
the Jewish state,
uh,
in,
in sort of biblical context,
there's tremendous argument between
whether a kingship is a good thing or a
kingship is a bad thing in the Old
Testament,
right?
I mean,
it says,
it says like Samuel,
Warren's the Jewish people,
if you take a king,
here's what's going to happen.
It's all going to suck,
right?
And then they form a kingship and things
suck.
And so there's a strong case to made the
kingship was not actually what was
wanted because you have an entire period
of just judges and the judges are
legitimately just individuals who are
trusted by the people,
but then they can be supplanted at
anytime by another judge who's not from
the lineage.
So,
you know,
so when we say that that group identity
matters in Judaism,
it matters to the extent that you're
following God's law.
But if you stray away from that,
the idea,
I think Judaism has always said that
what you do is what makes you part of
the group,
not what you are.
So Judaism has a weird dichotomy in it,
uh,
that's largely driven by exigent
circumstances,
which is the idea of biological Judaism
versus the idea of religious Judaism.
So I care very little about biological
Judaism,
like when somebody says such and such as
Jewish Noam Chomsky's Jewish,
like,
so what I really don't care.
And,
and I think that most orthodox Jews,
we basically biological Judaism or your
mom was Jewish,
which is the way that it works in
Orthodox Judaism is the sort of the
entry ticket to being Jewish,
meaning you have to either have
converted in or your mind has to be
Jewish in order for you to become fully
Jewish,
but the practice is what matters to me
more than anything else.
And that's where you get back into grey
space versus based a little bit.
Right?
It's also,
that's another place where the group
identity issue becomes paramount.
It's like,
well,
there's this group,
how has membership defined,
but let's say it's,
it's defined by ethnicity,
something which would be related to the
descent through the mother.
It's like,
well that's a problem.
I'm not saying it's wrong.
I'm saying it's uploaded demarcates.
A group say,
well,
this is a group that only we can belong
to.
What's weird is you can convert in my
way.
I'd say when there's play in the joints,
a lot of the problems are solvable
through the idea that you can convert
in.
Judaism says you can't convert out,
but then we don't punish people who
leave.
Right?
But is it right?
Which is different than Islam,
but yes,
it's actually a relatively important.
But I mean,
one of the people who I worked with at
my company,
Andrew Klavan is a guy who was born
Jewish and now is Christian,
right?
So in my view,
he's Jewish,
but am I going to like drag him down to
my synagogue?
Like that's not a thing.
So it's.
But uh,
I think that what the group identity
that the good,
the one thing I will say for a group
identity is that what we have seen is
that if there is lack of group identity,
that group identity is filled usually by
nefarious groups.
Meaning that people do have a necessity.
The idea of existing that you find your
meaning or your find your purpose or
your find your identity just in yourself
as an individual is not only wrong,
it's belied by virtually all of human
history.
Make an argument for identity politics,
but the point that,
but,
but what Judaism does,
what America does,
it says,
find your identity in the ideas.
Right?
That's the difference is when I'm.
So this is what I don't care about
biological Judaism,
you know,
particularly the,
to.
I care much more about the ideas that
you hold.
So I'm in favor of group identity.
If group identity is built around a set
of ideas that are worth preserving,
I'm not in favor of group identity.
Like I am a conservative.
That's a group identity,
right?
But that's an identifier more than it's
an identity.
Meaning it's a way of identifying me as
a person who thinks this way and because
I think there are differences in,
in modes of thought.
Then those group identities.
Do you matter?
I mean this is why we get together.
This is why we have discussions.
This is why we have friends,
family.
But I'm glad you.
I'm glad you said that the way you did
because I.
I try to challenge myself on that all
the time because I talk about the
individual.
I believe in the individual and I want
to make sure that I'm not going to let.
If I,
if we can,
and this is what I think is one of the
things that's broken down is we used to
have a common purpose.
Like I have this framework that I'm
working on in the book that I'm writing
where I basically say that in order for
an individual to be happy,
you need.
You need four things.
You need individual purpose.
You need individual capacity.
That the feeling that you can accomplish
that purpose or at least make moves in
that direction.
You need a communal purpose.
You do need to feel like you're part of
a group that's moving in the right
direction and you need to communal
capacity,
which both allows the community to
activate together and also protects your
rights as an individual to do what you
want to do in pursuit of your individual
purpose.
And that's the apotheosis of happiness.
And that's what I think the founding
fathers were trying to do in the United
States,
for example,
set up a framework where you could
fulfill all of these things,
but you do need the idea of communal
purpose.
And one of the things that's happened
post enlightenment is that people don't
even think in terms of they either think
purely in terms of communal purpose or
not at all in terms of communal purpose,
because they think either purely in
terms of communal purpose and that's
identity politics,
meaning I'm black for the black
community,
should do x,
or I'm Jewish,
therefore the Jewish community should do
x.
and then there are people who think not
in terms of communal purpose at all,
meaning full on libertarian.
I make my own meaning.
We don't have to have anything in
common.
We have.
And,
and that's a lie.
Even Libertarians believe we have to
have an idea of liberty and common live
with other people that were right.
Exactly.
Harmoniously.
And when we don't,
and when we don't have any of the.
When we don't have any sort of communal
purpose and we live with a bunch of
people with whom we share nothing,
then it falls apart incredibly quickly.
So here's,
here's how the Christian drama,
it looks to me it,
it addresses this issue,
right?
So Christ is presented as a figure who
is an absolute master of his tradition,
right?
He's debating with the Jewish elders
when he's 12.
So think about it psychologically is
first your child and you're dependent on
your parents and then you have to make
the move from being a child dependent
into the world,
but you don't move from child to
individually.
You move from child to group.
That's your teenage gang.
That's your adolescence.
You have to catalyze your group
identity.
If you don't have a group identity,
it's actually a developmental failure,
right?
But then you might think,
well wait,
a second group identity is necessary,
but is it the highest?
Is it?
Does it represent the highest plane of
moral achievement?
The answer to that is no.
You have to emerge from your group as an
individual.
Okay,
so now this is how I read the Christian
story symbolically,
and this is a consequence most of have
having students studied young.
He said,
look,
you need group identity.
That's the persona that you.
Where you have to have a persona.
You have to be able to wear a suit.
You have to be.
You have to simplify yourself for other
people.
You have to be able to play the game.
Otherwise you're.
You just have failed developmentally,
but if
you're only a persona,
then that's a big problem,
partly because when the group goes
insane,
so do you.
Okay,
now you got to emerge out of the group.
so now you need a symbol for what
emerges out of the group.
Okay,
so Christ is the symbol of what should
emerge out of the group.
Speaking,
psychologically,
bear the tragedy of life.
Speak the truth.
Be Willing to transform through death.
That's the rules.
Now I'm speaking purely psychologically.
You learn something new,
you learn it,
it makes you suffer.
The part of you that's wrong has to die.
You have to let go of that and it's
hard,
especially maybe you learn something
profound.
It's like,
it's like you have to regrow and arm.
It's really painful,
you know,
but you identify with the part of
yourself that transforms through
voluntary acceptance of suffering and
that's what Christ represents as a
symbol,
and I think that that's.
I think that that's correct.
Symbolically,
this is what actually severed the
relationship between Human Freud,
by the way,
because young laid out the,
his understanding of Christianity in
those terms and Freud,
it wasn't a Jewish Christian thing
because Freud was really he,
he was Jewish by ethnicity,
but no,
no,
not at all.
He just didn't want to have anything to
do with religious ideation at all.
He thought that that would introduce,
he called it like a tidal wave of black
title wave of cultism back into what he
regarded as a science.
He had his point,
but I think you've got the symbolic
structure.
Right,
and so what does that mean in
relationship to Christianity and
Judaism?
What's really complicated?
Because you have the prophetic tradition
in Judaism and the prophets are also
symbols of people who emerge from the
pathological group who stepped forward
courageously and who reconstitute the
group.
You believe these people could exist
right now,
which,
which people?
The profits.
I think profits of sorts exist always.
I think Dostoyevsky was a prophet niche.
It was clearly a profit.
I mean he predicted it was going to
happen in the 20th century.
Can you imagine predicting?
The reason I asked that was because I
think when people,
when you say profits,
I think people think of someone coming
down from heaven and they're going to
have a halo on or some crazy,
but you think that that's what I'm
trying to get to the right now.
I
fully agree with this.
In fact,
I was my manatees.
Manatees has an entire section in guide
for the perplexed about prophecy and
what he says is there's Moses level
prophecy which is the the legislating
profit which is and he says he's the
only legislating profit in the Jewish
view,
but all the other prophets are just
people who see things incredibly
clearly.
Essentially there are people who've
studied philosophy and who have studied
human morality and has studied the human
being and then that's the way down on
the iceberg.
That's just the thing that makes them
different.
Exactly.
And so in that sentence,
people who predicted the thing about,
you know,
providing a certain level of stability
for folks and we're,
you know,
I think,
I think there are levels of prophecy is
what I'll say and I think that the
better you are at,
at recognizing human behavior and the
interplay of forces,
the better
you are at saying,
okay,
here's what's going to happen next week.
I think it's very difficult for anybody
to say here's what's going to happen a
hundred years.
Because if you could predict that you
make a lot in the stock market,
but I think that you can certainly,
you know as well,
you can also get a sense of plate
tectonics like the details rob out.
But like,
and I think that's where we're at now.
Like I believe we're in,
we are in a war of ideas.
We're,
we're,
we're at a point where we're debating
the validity of postmodernism now and
that's tainted with neo Marxism and that
should have been laid to rest a hundred
years ago.
We're driving because that,
that just.
I mean,
the reason that the DMO postmodernist
can't let go of neo Marxism is because
there's no impetus forward in
postmodernism.
That's fundamental flaw.
It's like,
well,
there's no grand narrative.
It's okay.
Like,
what are you going to do tomorrow?
Well,
I don't know because everything's the
same as everything else.
It's like,
well,
you can't live.
You can't live that way.
It's impossible to live that way.
While I will just sneak some Marxism in
the back door,
it's like,
well,
that's.
That's prime a fascia evidence in my
estimation that your philosophy is
pragmatically lacking even though you
can make a perfectly coherent case for
it.
It's like you can't live it out.
You just can't do it,
so you have to sneak in this
pathological Marxism in the back door.
Well,
no,
that just invalidates your entire
system.
But apart from all that,
I think the postmodern objection to
meaning is actually wrong.
While we talked about this earlier,
I do believe that there is a
transcendent ethic and I do believe that
it touches on the metaphysical.
I believe if people experienced that
because people are perfectly capable of
having unalterably profound religious
experiences and the naturalistic
materialists don't know what the hell to
do with that,
they have no idea what to do with that
fact.
Say,
well,
it's delusional.
It's like,
well,
hang on a sec.
People who have those experiences appear
to be more successful and healthier,
so when exactly in what manner is that
delusional and if you induce it in the
lab with Psilocybin,
for example,
among people who are dying of cancer,
their fear of death goes away.
It's like that's you're going to just
lay of the lay that out there as
delusional or you quit smoking.
80 five percent success rate with one
mystical experience on psilocybin
produces 85 percent cessation rate and
smoking completely and with MDM,
a ecstasy.
The three treatments with Mtma.
That's what the current research
indicates produces a 72 percent cure
rate for intractable posttraumatic
stress disorder.
It's like those are miracle cures and no
one,
and they have to be accompanied by the
mystical experience.
No one knows how to account for that and
so there was a transfer,
so it's a very physical thing.
I mean in a case like that,
you talked about Iowa or any of these
things,
right,
that you're eating something,
you're ingesting something,
smoking it,
whatever it is.
It's physical.
It's here and now,
but the experience is metaphysical is
metaphase.
That's a place where the biological and
the transcendent touch and we don't know
what to make of that.
Well,
that's why psychedelics through our
whole culture into such a such a
flip this upside down.
No one knew what to do with them.
You know?
I mean the Indians regarded psilocybin
as food of the gods for a reason and
when people have encountered psychedelic
substances throughout human history,
that's always how they've been
characterized as,
right food of the gods.
It's like beware of them,
but there they opened the door to the
transcendent and well,
I think the evidence that they are doing
something that psychedelic substances
are doing something that we seriously
don't understand at all.
Not a bit is overwhelming.
Rick strassman wrote a book on his
experiences giving Dmt to a whole bunch
of people down in.
He was at in Austin,
I think strassman's a pretty straight
scientists,
you know,
he was interested in measuring
psychophysiological responses to the
drugs.
Well,
he'd give people dmt and they all came
back with the same story.
I was blasted out of my consciousness.
I went,
I met a whole bunch of alien beings.
They were really surprised I was there
and then I came back and it was the most
real thing that's ever happened to me.
And straussman would say,
well,
you know,
you had a Yogi and archetipal
experience,
or it was a dream and they'd say,
you don't understand.
Then he got so distraught because of
these continual reports that he had
stopped doing the research and like I'm
not making a claim for,
for anything metaphysical here,
but I'm definitely pointing out that
there are undeniable realms of human
experience that involve religious
experience and a sense of the infinite
transcendent that looked like they're
healthy and that you cannot deny well.
So what are you supposed to do with
that?
Well,
you sold a box and you say,
well,
we're not going to pay attention to.
It's like,
that's not gonna work.
Yeah,
that's not going to work.
And I've done a lot of those things that
you just mentioned and virtually always
had good experiences on them.
Now is someone that I'm pretty sure he's
never smoked weed mushrooms.
You haven't?
Okay.
You haven't done Mtma and all that stuff
will take a drink.
Yeah,
I mean I've done all of those things.
I don't really do.
Well.
I mean I smoked some weed but I don't.
I'm not doing.
I haven't done ecstasy and years and
mushrooms.
I did do about a year ago and I had a
great day and I kind of wandered around
and I thought I,
you know,
I felt some,
some things happening.
I didn't.
When I did them in college,
I had a couple of those type of
transcendent feeling.
I was just part of something,
whatever.
But.
So when you hear all this as someone
that doesn't partake in any of this
stuff,
what do you make of that?
That people can perhaps use some
substances that you're not down with on
a personal level to get to a place that
I think you actually think is a good
place.
I mean,
I think the answer is that it depends on
the level of expertise of the person
using it is what I would suggest,
you know,
the idea,
like I'm not against prescription
medication.
So if you're talking about,
you know,
an actual program that is going to
better somebody's life,
that's one thing.
But if it's somebody who's just,
I want to have a religious experience
than perhaps in Lsd.
And then there's some serious downsides
to drugs that I,
I do wonder if it is necessary it.
Well,
two things.
One,
the
in,
in Judaism,
and I keep reverting back to this
because I know it's the religion.
I know,
um,
but there,
there's two kinds of schools of thought
with regard to Judaism.
One are called the,
uh,
the,
the Ms Dot [inaudible].
These are people who are sort of
enlightenment mentality,
hard science folks.
And the Hasidim not considered murder.
The people he see really Kabod,
they have the,
the big beards.
And of the past,
uh,
and they,
and they like to dance and they drink
on,
on Purim and,
and all this and that.
They're wonderful people and they a
great outreach specifically because
they're so spiritual and I tend to be
more of this noggin than a,
than a faucet,
meaning that,
uh,
it's,
I,
I try to get to dance.
Oh,
it's nice operating.
Uh,
but I,
I,
I try to get to spirituality through
reason as opposed to through experience
simply because I think that,
well,
I know people who've had religious
experience and it's really changed them.
I think there are also a lot of people
have religious experience and it lasts
for a given amount of time and then
they're done with the religious
experience and they just go back to
doing whatever they're doing.
Right.
I mean this is what you were doing in
college.
So I think that if you're looking for
that as a gateway out of whatever it is
that is troubling you in terms of a lack
of purpose,
like a permanent solution,
maybe that works for a small number of
people.
But I,
I,
I highly doubt that most people can find
a level of purpose necessary to drive
the entirety of the rest of their lives
outside of a framework of conscious
will,
moving them in the direction of doing
the right thing.
You told people,
he talked about Mescalin and Lsd in the
context of Huxley's introduction of
those substances into the Western world.
And he said two things in is inimitably
wise manner.
The first thing he said is beware of
unearned wisdom,
man,
that's great.
And he also said you,
you have to be very careful about about
entering the realm of the gods because
you end up with a responsibility that
might be more crushing than you can
tolerate.
And it's the same kind of idea.
And I thought,
I've never read anyone who wrote wiser
words about the dangers of psychedelic
use than that because he didn't say,
well,
none of this is real.
He said it's more real than you want it
to be.
And so watch the hell out.
And I think that's extremely good advice
and it is very difficult for people to
integrate those experiences into their
life.
Although my experience with people has
been,
and I've seen this with lots of people,
they've said that they've done
mushrooms,
for example,
how to mystical experience and that that
provided them with a moral compass that
they lacked before.
That never went away.
And I've talked to many people who've
had that experience so,
but you know,
I've also been in Amsterdam watching the
50 year old punk rockers and beer and go
pound out some street kid.
There was the downside of transcendence
is something that's not to be trifled
with and there's also the opportunity
not to go to heaven but to go to hell.
And that does happen to people and that
can be,
that can induce posttraumatic stress
disorder essentially.
So,
you know,
be aware of,
be aware of wandering and realms,
not competent to wander,
rather they,
yeah,
that's my,
that's my central take.
And then I think it's really good for
you.
Like I think that what you're doing
really works because you know,
you,
you do Kinda what I
did with a biblical lectures except you
take it to an even greater extreme.
I would say you're so rational in your
approach,
like people know that you ever religious
over view,
let's say,
but you don't use that.
You use it less than I do,
I would say.
Yeah,
and I think it really works well for
you.
I think it's very.
I think it's hard to for his faith on
people and I don't think it's wrong to
force faith on people.
So if you want also counterproductive.
Exactly,
exactly.
And I,
I'm not preaching that you have to agree
with how I got to these values to say
that these values are necessary for the
civilization.
And this is essentially what I said to
Sam when I was debating him is his,
you know,
he said,
well,
you know,
a lot of religious people.
He sort of suggested that I think that
atheists can be moral people.
And I said,
I don't think that that's true at all.
I mean the point that I'm making is you
have to get to these valleys to have a
civilization.
How you get to those values,
in my view,
you know,
I think requires a leap of faith.
You can make that leap of faith a
variety of different ways,
but you're going to end up needing these
central values at road if you're gonna
build a civilization off of that,
so whether you do that through,
you know,
the,
the kind of method that the team wants
to get to.
What was weird is it,
you know,
Sam and I come from completely different
perspectives on virtually everything,
but we share probably 90 to 95 percent
of our values and so what I was
suggesting is that those values are
rooted in a Judeo Christian civilization
that is mixed with a Greek civilization
that brought us to the same place
because we grew up five miles from each
other.
So of course we have the same values,
right?
Yeah.
It was counter argument to that.
Basically would be that you're really
talking about enlightenment values,
but you would say those values
ultimately came to.
The funny thing about that is that's
actually a silly argument that those are
enlightenment.
I hope you guys will talk about when
you're on stage together.
Biologists have already made short
shrift of that.
It's like Sam can't be an evolutionary
biologist and say that the values that
run Western civilization sprang from the
enlightenment.
It's like you don't get to have those
two timeframes at the same time.
I may have slightly so putting words out
there and can see that I disagree with
you a little bit about the atheist issue
because I think this is the reason.
It's like if you think about the layers
of the mind with the iceberg analogy,
it's like,
well,
you've got your,
your,
your patterns of action,
and then you've got your justification
for those patterns of actually might
think that those are rational,
but,
but then there's something underneath
that which is like the images that
represent reality and the stories that
represent reality and then there's
something underneath that even and I
think that to be religious is to have
all of those things in order
simultaneously and I don't think that
you can have an ethic that's only
grounded in rationality because I think
the integrity of that rationality
depends on the type of stories that you
don't understand that that exists.
So let,
let me rephrase that.
I actually agree with everything you
just said when I say that we have to
ground these values in order for us to
build a civilization.
How you get there as your own business.
I mean on an individual level,
I don't mean that every way you get to
those values as equally valid or
otherwise it Sam and I would agree like
I,
I do not think that the,
the mode of thinking from evolutionary
biology to the values that I think are
necessary for building a civilization.
Even if I see weaknesses coming up in
Sam's representations for this reasons,
the first thing is he has to
dispense with consciousness and he has
to dispense with freewill and I actually
think that's deeply problematic and I
think the reason he has to do that and
Dennett does it too,
is because there is something
metaphysically strange about
consciousness and you can't allow for
that if you're a reductionist,
materialist.
And so I'm more than willing to say,
look,
I don't understand consciousness at all.
And the more I think about it,
the less I understand it because it
seems to be the linchpin of being
without consciousness.
There's no being we could say,
well the material reality continues.
It's like,
well maybe and maybe not because we do
not understand the relationship between
time and space and consciousness.
So there's no,
it's not self evident that what you're
saying is true.
It might be true,
but even if it was true,
well,
exactly.
How does the universe that has no
conscious ness in it exist?
Like how do you parameterize it?
Does it have a duration?
Does it have a size?
Does it have any qualities?
Like what is like a video game that no
one's playing,
right?
It's like,
well,
what is that exactly?
Well that this is,
this is where we get to,
you know,
back to that three hour conversation
that you and Sam had as to the nature of
truth and what exactly truth is.
And one of the things that I always
will,
I don't want to,
you know,
Critique Sam's ideology without him here
to defend himself.
Although it's fun.
It's definitely fun,
but we'll have to have been here to
actually actually do that.
It'd be a lot of fun.
But one of the things that I've always
found weird is that he and I have
precisely the same notion of an
objective truth,
but I don't understand where he's
getting his from,
meaning like I'm getting,
I don't either like,
well,
and he also,
because if he,
if he,
if you base your viewpoint on in a
materialist evolutionary biology than
what you would say,
w what you would say is the truth is
that which is most biologically
successful,
right?
That's the claim I was making when I
talked to Sam.
Right,
exactly.
Which is which is your claim,
and also a claim that leads to religion
because biologically speaking,
religious believers are more
biologically successful.
The nonreligious believers,
all history,
religious belief evolved,
right?
That's the thing.
Not only did religious belief evolve,
clearly it evolved.
It's one of the human universals.
The capacity for religious experience
evolved.
When you might say,
why?
Well maybe you could.
You could take the viewpoint that seems
to be characteristic of Steven pinker
and say,
well,
it's a spandrel.
It's just a side effect of something
more substantial.
In my objection to that is define your
spandrel first.
You know,
you don't get to eat right.
You don't get to define a way the side
effects of the drug.
Right,
exactly.
That's exactly it.
You know,
when people talk about drugs,
very often what they'll do is they'll
say,
well,
you know,
the drug is for a headache,
but it has the side effect of causing
your cancer.
It's like,
well,
no,
the drug causes cancer.
Yeah,
right.
They're getting rid of the headache is
the side effects.
I mean,
every one of those prescription
commercials,
you know,
headache,
diarrhea,
nausea,
thoughts of suicide,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But your cough,
Michael,
you know,
it's really nuts.
All right,
here's what we're doing.
So I want to be very respectful of,
of both of your times,
but yours particularly because you're
doing like a two hour lecture tended to
the orpheum.
There might be a surprise guest there.
I don't want to say who,
uh,
so we're gonna do a half hour more if
you guys can do that.
We're going to do a q and a from the
audience,
but I do want to ask guys one other
thing first and I just want to try to
get this to truly be as as personal as I
can get out of you guys in front of
thousands of thousands of people as
these last couple of years it happened
and as you both raising profile and
you're out there saying what you think
all the time and defending your beliefs
and being friends with people like Sam
who you disagree with on different
things and all that.
What,
what sort of been the most personal
thing that you've kind of struggled with
along the way?
I want to go deep before we open it up
to the audience.
Well,
for me it's two things.
One is for,
it's not so bad now.
It's still pretty bad.
Like I've lived in constant existential
terror of saying something that will be
fatal because I've been in this
situation for 15 months where,
well,
and there's been a few things that I've
done or said that have people have
argued skirted the edges and perhaps
they did.
Because if you say 10,000
things,
something's going to skirt the edge,
but I've been,
I've had to watch myself in an intensely
hypervigilant manner to ensure that I
don't provide those who would like to
provide those who regard me as their
enemy with the tools to dispense with me
and you know,
I have my family resting on me as well
as well as whatever else I happened to
be doing.
So that's been extraordinarily intense.
And the other thing is,
is persistent feeling of surreal
seriality that see one of this,
one of the markers of posttraumatic
stress disorder is that you can't
believe that what's happening to you is
real.
It's like I felt that for literally I
felt that way every single day since
September of 2016.
And so I just cannot get accustomed to.
Well,
even just to the scandals that I've been
involved in,
it's just one scandal after another,
you know,
and I,
I,
I don't know,
I don't have a frame of reference within
which to put this.
Yeah,
I think that I'll just briefly say for
myself,
I think,
I mean both of those,
right?
We're all afraid of the one thing that
you're going to accidentally just
misspeak or say something right out of
context.
You wave a meeting,
something stupid defending yourself in
which you could certainly do.
Right.
He had been writing columns since I was
17.
No,
I know there's one line with you that
you wanted one tweet that you sent that
you regret now and it's like,
I don't need to read the tweet in the
actual tweet thread.
I explained exactly what I meant in the
tweet,
but nobody ever reads the next tweet
that literally explains what I meant in
that tweet.
We don't even have to mention which
tweet to just add more fuel to the fire
button,
but very quickly because I do want to
get to the,
to the audience questions.
I think for me,
the second one is the one that I
struggled with it this surreal one
that's sometimes I'll look and see what
people are saying about Dave Rubin and I
and then I for a moment I'm like,
wait a minute.
I'm Dave Rubin.
I don't think any of them.
Even if I do think even if it's
something they're nice saying about me,
I'm like,
wait a minute,
that to me and,
and also just the other part of,
you know,
we,
we sort of live close to each other.
It'll proximity and I'll go out and,
you know,
the Petco will say something nice to me
and then for some reason they always,
they like Ben more but they look great.
But like I go out and then I'm like,
wow,
like the things that I'm doing has
meaning to people.
Like there's a lot of built in pressure
or at least for me,
there's a lot of responsibility.
Yeah.
Well I feel that too because now
whenever I go somewhere people come up
and they almost always say the same
thing.
They say,
you know,
I was in a pretty dark place and I'd
been listening to your lectures and
they've really helped.
Thanks a lot.
And I think,
man,
if you could have your wish and you
could,
what strangers would say to you on the
street?
What a cool thing.
No kidding.
But it's also kind of a terrifying thing
because you know,
people have pinned,
well,
let's say they've pinned their hopes on
what I,
what I'm saying,
that's the right way to say it,
but in some sense that also means they
pinned their hopes on me and like I'm
not by any stretch of the imagination
perfect far from it.
And so I do live in constant terror of
sinking my ship in a,
in a know,
in a particularly awful manner.
I still think that's the most likely.
Oh No,
I wake you up again.
This where you just wake up and terror
in the middle of the night that somebody
is going to take something that you said
out of context and you think,
did I really say it exactly the way I
meant to say it?
That didn't mean that that.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a definite thing.
And then you and it that the upside is
that people listen to what we're saying
and take it seriously.
And the downside is that people are
taking and taking it seriously.
So for you then,
would it be something,
I mean,
without getting too in the weeds,
like saying related to security or
something?
I mean,
you,
when you travel now you have to have
someone with you.
I mean,
it's ridiculous that I filed under
surreal because I actually have never
thought of myself as in serious physical
danger.
Even when people say you're serious
physical danger.
I think it was like this is America.
Am I really in fiscal?
Like whenever I do these lectures and
I've got a security team of 10 people
around me when I tell myself maybe it
was me whistling past the graveyard is
I'm the safest guy in the room.
I'm older.
Um,
but it's.
Yeah,
I mean that's weird.
The confluence of politics now is so
odd.
I mean,
the last night during the state of the
union,
they introduced trump as the president
of the United States and I just find
myself laughing out loud because what in
the world is going on?
Like I forget that I liked a lot of the
stuff he's doing,
like what in the world?
And,
and there's a,
I was reading a book about Brahms the
other day and in this book about Brahms,
it talks about how he's hobnobbing with,
uh,
with various other composers.
He's friends with Jacques and he is
fights with wagner and he's,
and he's,
and he's walking in these circles and I
thought,
wow,
that must have been a cool thing to walk
in these circles.
And then I look around and I realized
that the people that I work with in 100
years,
this may be the people that they're
writing about,
right?
Is like.
And that was the day that Shapiro got
together with Ruben and George Pearson
and talked about deep issues of
philosophy and you realize,
well,
how did we end up in this position?
Like this is one of the issues of
existential terror I have is are we the
best that we have to offer?
Like I look at all the people in the
White House for example,
I know like half the people in the White
House and I think is this the pinnacle,
like are like,
that's not a rip on the people in the
White House.
That's some grip on humanity,
like is this the best that we can do?
Am I even close to like,
why should I be in this position of
prominence?
Like there's got to be people smarter
than am I mean a lot
of them.
There's a beautiful thing I would hope
and I got it.
I asked somebody this,
so this thought experiment the other
day,
which would,
which would you prefer to be the
smartest man in the DM civilization or
the dumbest madness Martin civilization
and I think I can honestly say I prefer
to be the dumbest man in a smart
civilization and some sort of something
disquieting about being seen anyway as
one of the smart people and dumb
civilization.
Well,
you know what,
there are literally thousands of people
watching this live,
obviously in that election is over the
next couple of months and hopefully
there will be some people that will come
up with some better ideas than Ben
Shapiro and Jordan Olsen and Dave Rubin
and we'll find something else do.
All right.
Here's what we're gonna we're gonna.
Take a quick little break.
Uh,
I know already they're giving me the
signal.
We have roughly 400 billion questions.
We will do our best to be brief.
That's easy for you guys.
What we're known for.
That's another thing.
I've known him for A.
Alright,
so give us just like a minute or two.
Hang tight right there.
Uh,
the questions in a moment.
Alright guys,
we're going to try to plow through as
many questions as possible.
As I said,
Jordan is at the orpheum theater here in
downtown Los Angeles tonight.
Um,
it's sold out already,
right?
There's gonna be riots outside.
Uh,
but if you have a ticket you will see
Jordan later.
Uh,
here we go.
All right,
super chat for Jordan.
We're going to try to do these as
quickly as possible.
I've recently taken your understand
myself personality test and scored very
low in all aspects of agreeableness.
I have the cognitive ability to emulate
these aspects and do so for the benefit
of putting my kids in community here is
emulation or enough or do I have to
actually take the steps in showing and
honestly showing,
okay.
Agreeableness,
can you fake it?
Basically?
If,
if,
if emulation is motivated by a,
let's call it a noble aim,
the understanding that reciprocity is
necessary,
there is evidence showing that
disagreeable people do quite a bit
better if they go out of their way to do
things for other people too.
They make that a practice.
And the thing is,
is if,
if you're an introvert,
you have to become a conscious
extrovert,
right?
If you're,
if you're,
um,
so,
and if you're disagreeable,
you have to become consciously
agreeable.
You can do it.
And emulation is the first step to
incorporating it,
I would say.
So if you're doing it to manipulate
people,
well that's okay.
Different story,
man.
I mean there's,
there's a ton of people here that
donated on super chat just to say hi and
thank you.
So hello to everybody.
I'm a quick one for band.
I think we've already hit this,
but any chance of a future discussion
with Milo?
No.
Okay,
fair enough.
Um,
have something to say.
Okay.
Here's an interesting one.
And Jordan,
during the break mentioned that we
should be doing a show on the future at
some point.
Do you think like me,
that abortion and artificial
intelligence will eliminate humanity as
we know it?
I'm watching this new Philip k Dick
thing on Hulu now,
so
I'm very,
very into it.
Come on,
you can do it.
You're a Scifi guy.
You can get it.
We could talk about Ai.
Ai is going to transform what human
beings are dramatically.
We're going to have to decide in what
manner we want to be transformed and we
should bloody well hope and pray that
the people who are leading the
technological revolution are careful and
ethical.
People just don't.
It hasn't.
That ship sailed.
I mean,
I feel like we know already that that's
not how it's going to be.
We know there's so many problems related
to the diversity memo and the algorithms
and all that already from the tech
companies,
people working on these.
You shouldn't be.
You should be terrified of this
transhumanism.
It's like,
what do we want to turn into?
We need a vision of the future,
which is why we need to talk about the
future.
What am I think one of the things we
need to do collectively is to develop.
It's like,
okay,
I believe that the human race can do
anything it wants in the next 30 years.
You know,
Gates was talking.
Bill Gates was talking the other day
about eradicating malaria.
He's really set on eradicating the five
major transmissible diseases that could
happen.
We could eliminate most of our problems.
It's like,
well,
we should concentrate on the future that
we would like to have and try to bring
it into being and then maybe we can get
artificial intelligence to serve that
instead of serving whatever in Kuwait
and pathological set of principles that
it's serving now,
which we will suffer for it.
Yeah.
Well,
let's cross our fingers.
What is the likelihood that the sjw
postmodern left collapse will happen
soon?
Basically?
Um,
I think that it's more likely than
people think it is.
I'll put it that way.
I think that right now the,
the sjws think that they are on top and
they think that they are ascendant and I
think that the growing popularity of
people who are not that,
especially among young people,
I mean my entire audience is young
people like legitimately mind higher
audience is people who are under the age
of 40 and probably half.
It's under the age of 25 and I would,
I probably imagined since him for you
Jordan,
um,
you know,
I think that the,
there's a whole group of young people
who are just looking at this stuff and
innately saying I'm bored with it.
There's nothing here.
And so I think there's a good shot that
did the identity politics is actually an
older person's game.
Yeah.
Uh,
all right.
You know,
we're,
we're only gonna do two more.
What will,
we'll categorize,
categorize all of these and maybe next
time you guys are on,
we'll,
we'll get,
we'll hit some of these.
Um,
but we'll do two more because I think
they're good.
They sort of hit right where we're going
here.
Uh,
you both can answer this,
but it's directed to you,
Jordan,
any followup on your call earlier this
month for students to stand up and leave
the classroom whenever the teacher
mentions equity,
diversity and justice,
and I know this is something you've
talked about a bit about how you deal
with
college professor.
This was for junior high and high school
kids to talk to their parents about.
Well,
I was trying to provide people with easy
markers to note that their children are
being indoctrinated,
not educated,
and I said,
well,
if they're talk about equity,
diversity,
inclusivity,
white privilege or gender,
it's time to leave the class.
And I,
and now that didn't cause nearly as much
trouble that video is.
I thought it might be.
That's a pretty dangerous idea to be
telling that to a 13,
14.
Yes.
But it's also dangerous not to tell them
that.
And I mean it's particularly Germane in
Ontario where the elementary teachers,
Federation of Ontario has explicitly
developed a social justice curriculum
with that name,
whose explicit purpose is to transform
kids from kindergarten to grade eight
into social justice activists.
They've even bent the selection of
literature to promote that,
so they're perverting art for ideology
and that's the official policy,
the elementary teachers,
Federation of Ontario,
if they're going to do that,
play that game.
Then for me to say,
look,
here's five phrases that that are pretty
decently diagnostic.
You can be pretty certain that if these
topics come up in your class that you're
now into indoctrination territory.
Yeah,
I think people should walk.
What's the risk though of saying that to
a kid that may come home and the parents
may not even understand these issues
enough to defend risk,
risk everywhere,
man,
it's,
it's the risk of going along with it.
There's the risk of standing up against
it and I believe,
and that's why I've been doing what I've
been doing,
is that I believe that the risk of
stating that this is dangerous and
should stop is way less than the risk of
going along with it.
All right,
so this is going to be.
This is gonna be the last one for now.
We will pick this up at another point
and we also discussed during the break
that maybe we can do some kind of live
thing together with this whole crew of
people that we're talking about.
We'll see who we can get to that
probably in la,
but we'll see.
Uh,
this one,
I'm sure I've asked you some form of
this in our other interviews before,
but I think it's,
it's the one that sort of handed this
back to the,
to the audience for both of you for some
time now.
I've wanted to start doing something to
protect liberty and western values,
et Cetera,
but I have no idea where to start.
What's the most useful thing I can do to
start as an average person?
I mean,
I think that my answer,
this is sort of the same answer as to
what you just do in life generally.
Find something that you're good at,
find something you like to do and find
something that's useful.
And where are those three things kind of
conflate?
Well,
what are those three things?
Overlap.
That's where you're going to be the
happiest and that's where you're gonna
feel you're making a difference because
if you only have two of those three
things,
then you're butting your head against a
brick wall.
If you'd like to do something and you
think that it's going to influence other
people,
but you suck at it,
it's not going to work for you.
So try to openly identify your own
skillset,
find what it is that you're good at,
and then figure,
how do I use this skill set something
I'm good at and enjoy doing?
How do I use that for a purpose that is,
that is useful,
and it sounds like you already have your
purpose.
It's just a question of what can you do
that that actually helps effectuate that
purpose without knowing your skillset.
I don't know,
but if I knew your skillset,
then I could help define what you could
do with that to get from point a to
point b.
So I suspect you probably.
Yeah,
but what about the courage,
but I would just add a little bit to
that.
It's like there are some things that you
will see that will bother you.
Some of those are your problems.
That's why they bother you.
Like there's lots of things in the world
that are happening that don't bother
you.
It's like they're not your problems.
The things that bother you for some
reason or your problems.
Find something that bothers you,
that you could fix,
that you could start fixing and start
fixing it.
That's,
that's it.
And you know you should do it
competently.
Doing a domain where you're competent in
a domain where you're interested,
but there are things that you'll see
around you that you think couldn't be
set right that you could set.
Right.
It's like,
go for it.
You'll get good at it,
and then you will get bigger and bigger
things.
Right.
That's,
that's,
that's where to start.
Start small.
You won't end small.
I mean I can tell you in the most
intimate way as you guys are now in my
house,
in my studio that we built,
that's funded by the people that are
watching this.
I just had an idea that I started
talking about it.
I started a youtube channel that
literally everyone watching this can do.
You start.
I mean,
look at the three of us.
We all started putting stuff out there
going,
is this going to work?
None of us were greenlit.
I've never been greenlit or had any
respect from the industrial together.
Listen guys,
it was a pleasure.
Really.
What do you do before so you can take a
nap.
Maybe.
I'm definitely going to take a nap.
You don't take naps because Ben Shapiro
take that nap.
Yeah,
I have two kids.
They're both and one just turned four
yesterday.
Take nap.
Fair enough.
It's been a pleasure.
Guys will figure out some ways to expand
this to the wider group and do some live
events and everything else and we'll.
We'll keep this conversation going.
Thank you guys for all the comments.
I promise you.
We're gonna.
We're gonna list everything out,
so whether you submitted on superchat or
patron,
we'll try to get back to all this stuff
and when I do my live streams,
I'll try to address some of this
directly.
So thanks for watching and thank you for
Youtube for actually allowing the stream
to be up.
What are the chances were
monetized by tomorrow.
Alright God,
I'd hate bet.
Luckily I haven't been demonetized is.
I don't have any ads sent me self select
that.
Alright.
Alright great.
Thanks everybody.
Nice.
Good.